it's the world's oldest and largest
organization that promotes Islamic
principles in public life the Muslim
Brotherhood the group was created in
Egypt in 1928 by a schoolteacher in
intestine and vendor who wanted to
reform society after years of corruption
inequality and colonial rule he
advocated for Islamic values in
government to promote a more moral
society the Brotherhood continued to
grow despite a 1954 ban for trying to
overthrow Egypt's leaders members
remained underground or imprisoned until
the 1970s the Brotherhood renounced
violence and were gradually released and
tolerated to an extent they remained
illegal and were subject to crackdowns
but the Brotherhood earned broad support
by building social services like
hospitals and schools
they also inspired branches countries
across the globe
when Egypt's president was overthrown in
2011 the group won the elections that
followed but the Brotherhood's rule was
marked by widespread frustration they're
accused of economic mismanagement and
poor governance in 2013 the military
took power in a coup and outlawed the
Muslim Brotherhood again since then
thousands of Brotherhood supporters and
other opposition activists have been
imprisoned hundreds more have been
sentenced to death